SPEAKER 1: Hey, everyone.
So I'm going to introduce
Dr. Abigail Person who
is an associate
professor and co-director
of the neuroscience program
at the University of Colorado
School of Medicine.
She's an expert in
understanding the computations
in the cerebellum and its role
in smooth and precise movement
Dr. Person has been awarded
the Boettcher Foundation
Webb-Waring Biomedical Research
Award and the Esther A.
And Joseph Klingenstein Fund
Award in the Neurosciences.
Please welcome her.
ABIGAIL PERSON: All
right, well, it's
a delight to be here seeing
the heroes of the field
in every direction.
And so I really want to thank
[INAUDIBLE] for the invitation.
It means a lot.
So with that, I heard that MIT
is not a place for compliments,
and so I'm going to start with
an image of Mount Harvard,
not to create a cross-town
rivalry or anything
but just to introduce
you to my home state.
I've been giving a
lot of Zoom talks,
and since I don't go there, I
bring myself to other people,
but this hasn't yet changed.
So I present to
you Mount Harvard.
Now, the reason I'm showing
you this isn't really
just because I'm from
Colorado but because if we
were to gaze up onto
one of these snowfields,
we might see a
creature like this.
This mountain goat is
in fact demonstrating
a kind of precise action
which really motivates many
of the questions in my lab.
So you can see that it's really
reaching for its next foothold
here, not unlike this now famous
climber Alex Honnold, who's
reaching for his next
handhold on his certifiably
insane rope-less ascent of
El Capitan in California.
So I hope you can appreciate
that the precision of movement
is a life or death scenario
for these creatures.
One imprecise
movement could lead
to the death of these animals.
And so we're very interested in
how the brain actually mediates
these kinds of behaviors.
Now, it turns out that
Alex Honnold has actually
had his brain scanned, and
there's something wrong,
evidently, with his amygdala.
But I would argue that
there's absolutely nothing
wrong with his
cerebellum, and the reason
that I can make that
speculation is that we've
known for over 100
years, really starting
with the work of a British
physician named Gordon
Holmes who studied World War
I veterans who suffered fairly
localized cerebellar
lesions, to this man who
has a unilateral cerebellar
lesion, that the cerebellum is
critical for precise
reaching movements.
So I'm going to
show you this movie.
This man is going
to reach to his nose
with his unaffected
limb, and then he's
going to reach to his nose
with his affected limb.
And you'll easily see
the kind of motor deficit
that characterizes
cerebellar damage.
So that's the good nose--
or that's the good arm,
and this is the bad arm.
So with the good
arm, he precisely
slows to touch his nose.
With the bad arm he oscillates
right around that end point.
So these oscillations, which
I'll show you one more time,
have resonance with all
kinds of control theory
that I think many engineers
are very familiar with,
with control systems.
So the problem is that when
sensory feedback is delayed
relative to the output of the
system, that there's naturally
oscillations that emerge.
So the way I often
describe this with reaching
movements is if you were to
merely use your visual system
to reach for a particular
glass of water or something,
the visual information would
be way out of date by the time
your fast reach brought
your limb to that target,
and you'd overshoot the target.
Then you would overcorrect,
and you would overshoot.
And so that's essentially
what people hypothesize
these oscillations
around end points
are in patients with
cerebellar damage.
And so it suggests that the
cerebellum may be computing
some kind of anticipatory
control that sort of obviates
this problem in
the nervous system.
This slow sensory
feedback problem.
So this is kind of
the working framework
that we have in the lab
is that the cerebellum may
be generating some kind
of anticipatory control.
And there's a lot
of work that tries
to map the sort of
nature of information
that enters the cerebellum
through the mossy fibers
into the cerebellum
that sort of takes
two flavors, either sensory
information or motor
information.
This ends up providing a very
rich spatial temporal context
for every movement that's
represented in the granule cell
layer, which then projects
into the Purkinje cell layer.
The Purkinje
neurons are the sort
of learning workhorses
of the cerebellum,
and there are many theories
about what they compute.
I'm going to skip
over all of the debate
and just call it
an internal model.
It's some kind of representation
of the body that's
localized to whatever sort of
effector we're talking about.
Those Purkinje neurons are
inhibitory projection neurons.
They project down to
the output structures
of the cerebellum which
are the cerebellar nuclei.
The cerebellar nuclei
then distribute the output
computation of the cerebellum
to many different areas,
and that is sort of modular
depending on what cerebellar
nucleus we're talking about
along this medial to lateral
dimension.
So this is the theory that we
have that we get to work with.
But when we started the lab, the
evidence for any kind of feed
forward control coming
out of the cerebellum
was very marginal.
And so we wanted
to know where do
we look for evidence of feed
forward anticipatory control.
Well, we really
relied on data sets
that had been generated over
the years investigating limb
movements in a
variety of creatures,
including cats,
monkeys, and mice.
And several papers, including
work from Claude Getz's lab
as well as work from
Albert Chen's lab,
identified a particular
output structure,
the anterior interposed
nucleus, as being
critical for limb movements.
So they would use either
muscimol inactivation
or genetic lesions
of output neurons
and found that those kinds
of inactivation schemes
recapitulated the
phenomenon of dysmetria.
And so this gave us a place
to look but by no means
really isolated an
anticipatory control signature
because these long term
inactivations don't distinguish
between problems
in motor planning
or identify control policies.
And so that's really where
we began when we wanted
to interrogate this idea.
So the first work
I'm going to show you
is all work from a
fantastic graduate student
in the lab, Matt Becker.
He combined a real time, three
dimensional limb tracking
with electrophysiology
and optogenetics
to address this question of what
does the interposed nucleus do
to control reaching movements?
And so he used a
motion capture system
so that we could
essentially get real time
readout of movement kinematics.
And we use a mouse model for
many of the obvious reasons.
And it's nice because
these reaching movements
are fairly discrete, so we
can look at many of them mice.
Will readily engage
in this task,
and we had this place to look
for some kind of cerebellar
control.
So the first observation
we made using
electrophysiological recordings
from the interposed nucleus
is that neurons in
the interposed nucleus
are modulated during reach.
So you can see an
example neuron here
where here we've aligned neural
activity to the reach onset,
and you can see that
the cells are modulated.
However, this modulation is
really rather sloppy from trial
to trial, as I think
you can appreciate.
However, if we simply
align the neural data
to the end point
of reaches, we find
that the neural
activity is, in fact,
much more sharply regulated.
And so this was
interesting to us
because as you might
recall from the video,
it's movement
endpoints that seem
to be preferentially
disturbed in patients
with cerebellar damage.
Indeed, we saw this kind
of end point modulation
in many neurons within
the interposed nucleus.
By no means all of the neurons,
but many of these cells
showed this kind of
endpoint related activity
which you can see
sort of happens right
during this decelerated phase
of the reaching movement.
And so the natural
question that we asked
is, is this activity
causal for limb control?
So to address this question,
we introduced channelrhodopsin
to the output neurons
of the cerebellar nuclei
within the anterior
interposed nucleus,
implant an optical
fiber over [? ente, ?]
and then used closed loop
optogenetic stimulation just
during reach on
randomized 25% of reaches
and asked what's the
kinematic consequence
of this perturbation.
So this is a short stimulus.
You'll see it displayed
up in the top,
and it's illustrated
here as well.
So here's a mouse.
It gets stimulated,
ends up with the pellet.
Sometimes they don't
get the pellet, however,
so let's look at many reaches.
So this illustration
shows unstimulated reaches
in orange and stimulated
reaches in blue.
The point of the 50 millisecond
stimulation stimulus train
is shown here, and then I pull
down stills from this movie
down here.
And so what you can see
is early in the reach,
these reaches are
indistinguishable,
as you would expect.
But right after the
stimulation, you
can see that the stimulated
reaches are not as far out,
and they're not as
far up, and then
there's only a late
phase correction.
And so if we looked
at these reaches
in sort of outward
velocity space,
we'd find that the outward
velocity slows rapidly
in response to stimulation.
And the upshot
here is that these
reaches end up hypometric.
So the mouse is not
reaching as far in response
to this stimulation.
So I am going to
skip a bunch of data,
but we can show that
modulating the strength
of optogenetic
stimulation modulates
the strength of the
kinematic effect,
and that we can deliver
this stimulation
at any point in
reach and always see
this reduction in
outward velocity.
So the obvious
question, then, if we
want to interpret the
activity that we observed
in the interposed nucleus
as causal for deceleration,
is that we should be
able to reduce activity
in that structure and
see the opposite effect.
And so we did this experiment
where we introduced arch
into the interposed nucleus.
What we found is, indeed,
a consistent increase
in all nine animals
that we tested this
in in the outward velocity.
So here we're sort of under
some biomechanical constraints
of the sort of
length of the limb,
but we see this very consistent
increase in outward velocity
during the arch inactivation
of the nucleus and concomitant
overshooting of the
reach end point.
So these data,
summarized, give this idea
that this activity in
the interposed nucleus
acts as some kind
of a velocity dial
to regulate limb
kinematics, but there
are a lot of potential
interpretations of these data.
So for example, we know that
activity from the motor cortex
is critical for driving
these movements.
This is in mice.
Beautiful work done by Adam
Hantman's group, where they've
inactivated motor
cortex during reach,
and that halts the
movement entirely.
So what is this
structure, the cerebellum,
doing to these putative
commands from motor cortex?
So our data are consistent
with at least two models.
The first is that maybe this
activity from cerebellum
is acting like something like
a brake or a gain controller.
So if you imagine some sort
of an unfettered command
from cortex
generating a movement
with a particular outward
and upward velocity,
and then we stimulate the
cerebellum, and that's reduced.
So that's one possibility.
An equally tenable
possibility is
that there's some kind of a
directional command that's
in the opposite direction that
is being added to this control
signal from motor cortex.
So these two possibilities
are interesting because they
make distinguishable
hypotheses about what
should happen if we stimulate
on return of the movement.
So if we stimulate on return and
we are activating or reducing
the gain of that command or
we're just breaking the limb,
then we should show that
the limb will slow down
in response to that
stimulation, Alternatively,
if we're introducing sort of
a return vector of command,
we should actually
speed the limb up
if we stimulate on return.
So we performed this
experiment, and our data
are consistent with this model
because when we stimulate
in the negative
velocity domain, we
find that the limb actually goes
faster in the return direction.
So these data support
the view that there
is some kind of a summation
of directional control vectors
that are mediating the limb
movements in this paradigm.
So we wanted to return
to the neural data
and ask a little bit of a
deeper question about refinement
of movement by the cerebellum.
So we sorted reaches
by the firing rates
that were issued by
the interposed nucleus
during a particular reach and
separated those into deciles,
which are color-coded here.
So the reaches that had
the highest firing rate,
not surprisingly what
I've already shown you,
decelerated the fastest, and
those with the lowest firing
rates decelerated the slowest.
And this is also consistent
with other linear correlation
analyzes that we did.
But why should we expect
trial-by-trial variability
in the firing rates
to happen at all?
So to address this,
we went back in time
from the epoch that we're
analyzing for firing rates here
and looked at the peak
velocity of the reaches.
And we found that reaches
that decelerated the fastest
and had the highest
firing rates also
had the highest peak
velocities, and reaches
that decelerated the slowest
and had the lowest firing
rates also had the
lowest peak velocities.
So this gets a little
bit wobbly, so--
but the upshot is if that-- is
that the end points, regardless
of this initial kinematic
variability, were stable.
So if the animal reached slowly,
it would decelerate slowly,
and it would end on target.
And if it reached very fast, it
would decelerate very quickly
and end on target.
And so the model
that we proposed
is that this activity
that's regulated
on a reach-by-reach reach
basis in the interposed nucleus
is accommodating a deceleration
that allows the limb
to end on target.
And we can illustrate
that if you did not
have this kind of scaled
activity from the interpose,
that reaches that
started out very slow
and had an average
rate of deceleration
would end hypometric.
So they would slow down
essentially too fast
for a particular end point.
Conversely, reaches that
start out very fast and do not
decelerate fast
enough would end up
hypermetric with the average
deceleration profile.
So by regulating this
late-phase kinematic feature,
the cerebellum may improve
the precision of movements.
So that's kind of the
model that we had going,
where we have this
kind of peak velocity
that scales activity in
the interposed nucleus
to regulate the decelerative
phase of the reaching movement.
And so the next question
that we wanted to address
is how this computation
might actually be made.
And so to address this, we
made the very not controversial
decision to look at the
Purkinje neurons which
are, of course, the major driver
to the interposed nucleus.
And so another very
talented student
in the lab, Dylan
Calame, ended up
targeting his neural recordings
to a part of the cerebellar
cortex that had previously been
identified by Tom Otis's lab
as controlling or
at least influencing
forelimb movements in mice.
And so, indeed, when he
recorded in this region,
he found many Purkinje neurons
that modulate their activity
around the time of reach.
And so he could look at entire
populations of these cells
and find that there were cells
that increase their firing
rate around the time
of reach and cells
that decrease their firing
rate around the reach.
I should say that these are
all high firing rate cells.
Many of them have
complex spikes,
and that's how we're identifying
them as Purkinje cells.
So if we look at population
PSTHs of these two populations,
these increasers and
decreasers, if you will,
we find that they're practically
mirror images of the two.
And for a very
long time, we were
spending a lot of
time doing all kinds
of sophisticated
regression techniques
to try to understand what
are these individual neurons
encoding?
What are the kinematic
features of their code?
And I can bore you
with bar graphs that
are 18 parameters
long, and so I was.
We were just boring ourselves
with all of this data.
And Reza Shadmehr
came and visited,
and he has been at the forefront
of thinking about populations
of Purkinje neurons
sort of conspiring
to generate comprehensive
codes at the population level.
And he said, well, why don't
you just see what they're all
doing if you mix them up?
And so we did.
We combined all of these
neural recordings together,
and what we found was really
remarkable, given what
we had observed in the
interposed nucleus, which
to remind you, was
a linear scaling
of the increase in activity with
the magnitude of the decrease,
and it's scaled
with peak velocity.
So what we observed in the
Purkinje neurons, which
are here sorted
by peak velocity,
is that there was a net
decrease in the activity
of the population
of Purkinje neurons
that also scaled in magnitude
relative to peak velocity.
So the largest
pauses were happening
with the very fastest reaches,
and it sort of scales linearly.
So if we match that magnitude
of a pause, if you will,
on to the scaled activity
of the interposed nucleus,
it stands to reason that
this disinhibition may
sort of regulate the amplitude
of the activity that's coming
out of the interposed nucleus.
So that was a lot, but I hope
that you followed all that.
So I showed you now what
Purkinje neurons are doing,
but I started this section
with this question of how
this computation might be made.
And so I need to
take a little detour
into teaching you a little bit
more about cerebellar theory
in order to get here.
And before I do
that, I want to point
at two temporal relationships
that emerge from these data.
The first is that the max
outward acceleration peak
velocity, those are
parameters in kinematic space
that happened
before deceleration.
It's kind of obvious
that the reach kinematics
have a bell-shaped profile.
So they accelerate then
decelerate to end point.
But also, in patients
with cerebellar damage,
the timing of agonist
and [? braking ?]
antagonist muscles that's
seen in healthy patients
is delayed in
cerebellar patients.
So there's some kind of this
and then that relationship
that emerges in
coordinated movements.
And so we hypothesized
that this peak velocity
is serving as something
of a contextual cue
to the cerebellum
to then regulate
the amplitude of deceleration
by the structure.
And so to expand on
this idea that there's
an association between
a this and then that,
we're going to take a left turn.
I'm going to remind
people about cerebellar
associative learning,
and then we're
going to get back to reaching.
So many people in their sort
of introductory neuroscience
classes will learn about
delay eyelid conditioning
in cerebellum, at which
point they'll fall asleep,
and then they'll wake
up again when people
are talking about cognition.
But I'm going to beg
for your attention here.
So in delay eyelid conditioning,
classic Pavlovian sorts
of pairings, there's a
neutral conditioned stimulus.
In this case, it's a tone.
The tone is played for
several hundred milliseconds.
And at the very end
of the tone, a puff
is delivered-- an air puff
is delivered to the eye.
This is an aversive stimulus
that causes a reflexive eye
blink in naive animals.
After repeated pairings
of the tone and the puff,
the tone and the puff,
the animal learns to close its
eyelid just before the puff is
about to come.
So you can see that there's
this learned component
to anticipating the
time of the air puff.
Now, one critical piece of
this associative learning
is that there's a
time component to it.
So the animal does
not close its eye
at the beginning of the tone.
It closes its eyelid
right before the puff
is going to happen.
And so neuroscientists like
Mike Mock and Dean Bonomo
have thought deeply about how
it is that this timing can
be learned.
I should also add
that decades of work
showed that this task
requires the cerebellum.
So we think this is
actually happening
within the cerebellum,
but the basic upshot
is that the mossy fiber
inputs to the cerebellum
carry this tone activity
and that granule cells break
that invariant tone
activity up into what
is called a temporal basis set.
So there's sort
of chunks of time
that are represented by small
populations of granule cells.
Each one of those
populations converges
onto a Purkinje neuron, which
under the naive condition,
isn't doing anything except
inhibiting the nuclei,
and so there's no behavior.
So what happens in the
presence of a puff of air
is that there is activity that
is generated in what is called
the inferior olive
which is a teaching
signal to the cerebellum,
details alighted.
The point is that when this
teaching signal happens,
there is a concomitant change
in the strength of granule cell
inputs to Purkinje neurons but
only in the cells that were
active right before the puff.
So this is how time
might then be associated
with an aversive event.
That reduction in
synaptic strength
leads to pauses
in Purkinje cells
and common concomitant
disinhibition of the cerebellar
nuclei, and then that leads
to the conditioned response.
So we hypothesized
that this activity
that we see during
reaching movements
in the interposed nucleus is
akin to a conditioned response.
That is, it's responding to
some sort of initial cue.
What does this have to do
with reach adaptation, right?
So I showed you
these velocity traces
of the reaching movement, this
bell shaped velocity profile.
And so we would argue
that, let's say,
that this is going
to be a bad reach.
It's going to
overshoot its target.
So we have this initial
kinematic information
coming into the cerebellum
through the mossy fiber
pathway.
If it overshoots its
target, maybe there's
a complex spike, that
complex spike then
is going to go to
the Purkinje neurons,
change the synaptic
weights of the granule
cells that were active during
that sort of peak velocity
phase.
Then, when this reach happens
again, the same people--
or the same peak
velocity may be reached,
but because of this
associative plasticity,
we think that there may be
an increase in the activity
of the nuclear neurons to
sort of drive reach slowing
to increase the rate of
deceleration and land
on target.
So that's our
working hypothesis.
How on Earth do we
test any of this?
So one of the
tricks of the delay
eyelid conditioning
field is to substitute
the conditioned stimulus with
electrical or optogenetic
stimulation of mossy
fiber pathway directly.
So this way you get around of
all the other stuff going on
in the brain, and you just
introduce the stimulus here.
And you can fictively associate
those things in rabbits.
We don't have that
luxury because we're
looking at this
naturalistic movement,
but we borrowed a sort
of trick from them.
And so instead of
perturbing a reach
through some sort
of external means,
we're going to perturb a
reach through activation
of the mossy fiber
pathways themselves.
So we're essentially
superimposing
some kind of novel contextual
input into the circuit.
And so to do this, we
introduced channelrhodopsin
into the pontine nucleus of
the mouse, which expresses then
channelrhodopsin in the
mossy fibers very densely.
And then implant
an optical fiber,
and then perform an
experiment that's
conceptually similar to
the ones I showed you
in the interposed nucleus
where we stimulate in closed
loop with the movement.
In this case, we're stimulating
slightly differently
because we're going to do
this in a block format.
So rather than stimulating
in randomized ways,
we're going to stimulate such
that the animal can actually
hope to learn that every
reach gets this perturbation.
So also work from Adam
[? Hampton's ?] lab
had shown that stimulation
of the pontine fibers
can perturb the reach.
So we had good reason
to think that there
might be some kind of a
learnable contingency here.
So indeed, we found that
optogenetic activation
of the pontine afferents
caused overshoot
of the reaching movement.
However, if we continuously
deliver that stimulus,
that effect of that
stimulus actually adapts.
So there's less of
a kinematic effect
late in the stimulus
block compared to early,
and when we turn
off the stimulus,
we see that there's
this opposite overshoot.
This is classic hallmark
of cerebellar adaptation.
So this is cool.
Now we've got an
adaptation paradigm
that we can use to explore
this idea, that re-adapts.
So we saw that in all
animals that we've tested.
We know that activation
of these cells--
of these afferents
actually causes changes
in Purkinje cells,
but what happens
during that
within-session adaptation?
So to address this we've now
recorded from Purkinje neurons
during adaptation.
Skipping over some
details, neurons--
well, I don't have to.
Sometimes neurons are
activated by this stimulus
and other neurons are
inhibited sort of similar
to that kind of balance
of bursters and pausers
that I showed you about earlier.
And so we grouped
cells, either they
were activated by stimulation
or inactivated by stimulation,
and watched how that
progressed through the course
of adaptation.
And what we found
is that neurons
that showed an activation to--
in response to optogenetic
stimulation or inactivation
in response slowly decay
back to essentially baseline.
So if we look at
p-value maps, we
find that there's a
very high difference
between the stimulated and
control profiles of Purkinje
neurons early in the
stimulation block,
and that decays
with multiple trials
over the course of the block.
And so this is very cool.
This is within-session
adaptation,
and it brings us to a question
of how is this happening?
So I'm not going to go into much
of the details of this model,
but we hypothesized sort of
consistent with the [? Mock ?]
and [? Bonomono ?] work
that there's a time varying
population of granule cells
active during the reach
and that our optogenetic
perturbation is driving
activity within this population,
which is then sort of decaying
back to its target
zone during adaptation.
So it's interesting, if we look
at which synapses are actually
undergoing change during
this adaptation block,
we find that, of course,
the granule cells that we're
driving with our optogenetics,
they're changing,
so their weights are decayed.
But what's important to note
is that neurons that we are not
explicitly driving
are also changing
but in this way that's
temporally locked
to the stimulus.
And we think that this sort
of application of plasticity
to neurons that weren't
causing the problem
but were sort of
just coincidentally
active during the
perturbation is
essential for the
emergence of after effects
that are considered to be
the hallmark of learning.
But we consider
them to be evidence
that there's a
misattribution of error
to the coincidentally
active cells.
So I'll end there
to summarize that we
think that we have at least the
beginnings of a model for feed
forward control during
a volitional movement
in the cerebellum.
And that through
our experiments,
we have an idea that there
may be a conditioned response
in the nucleus that's
structuring precision
of endpoint that may be
learned by the population
activity in Purkinje cells and
that that is sort of temporally
produced through what
we think is happening
is a basis that is
forming in response
to naturalistic inputs,
which I didn't get into.
So I want to thank the
very wonderful people
I get to work with, Matt Becker
and Dylan Calame, most notably,
for this talk.
And with that I'm happy
to take any questions.
I realize I went fast.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks so
much for the great talk.
We have few minutes
for audience questions.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you Abby.
I really enjoyed that talk.
Any-- this is just
a detail question.
Any idea what mechanism
is responsible
for sort of staggering
the delays of these cells?
ABIGAIL PERSON: Yeah, we have
a lot of ideas about that,
actually.
So I actually have a
figure from a manuscript
that is on bioRxiv now that is
explicitly about this topic.
How does a base-- how
would a temporal basis set
form in the granule cell layer?
So this idea has
stumped the people
that are studying the eyelid
conditioning because what
they have is an invariant
signal coming in.
And so they hypothesize
that there's
recurrent [? inhibition, ?]
and there's
all these kinds of specialized
mechanisms in the granule cell
layer itself.
So my student Jessie Gilmer,
whose work I didn't talk about,
he was building some models.
And he showed this one figure,
and it had this basis set,
and I was like, where
did that come from?
He's like, oh, I just put
in some naturalistic inputs.
And so this was
surprising because I
don't think that
the people studying
the naturalistic movements had
really engaged with the timing
problem.
But it turns out if you
have time varying inputs
in the mossy fibers, which we
model as Ornstein-Uhlenbeck
functions that have an
autocorrelation time of about
100 milliseconds sort of similar
to the activity of mossy fiber
afferents, if you put
that structure of input
into a very simple model
of a summation circuit
in the granule cell layer where
each granule cell receives four
of these sort of noisy inputs,
that this basis set is just
an emergent property.
It's actually very trivial
for the granule cell layer
to generate this.
It requires a
level of inhibition
that can float with
this, but that's
very consistent with the
inter-neuron network of Golgi
cells in the cerebellar cortex.
So we think this is a highly
likely thing to happen.
SPEAKER 3: Larry
Abbott and Nate Sawtell
have similar ideas in like--
ABIGAIL PERSON: In electric
fish, that's right.
So they have-- so in
the Kennedy paper from--
in Ann Kennedy's paper
from Nate Sawtell's lab,
they have this nice basis
set that they have observed
in fish granule cells, which
is probably the clearest basis
that anyone has in
a granule cell layer
in a cerebellar-like structure.
So with their-- at least
when I've talked to Nate,
I think that they
think that there's
a-- because those electric organ
discharges are quite pulsatile,
they think that there's
a special neuron called
a unipolar brush shell
that sort of extending
the duration of that pulsatile
length signal, which we think
is slightly different than
this kind of continuous motor
signal that might be--
motor and sensory sort
of reafference signal that would
be coming into the cerebellum
through the mossy fibers,
but it's a very good point.
So, right, we talked about it
with the post-docs and students
earlier today about
how there is really
a dearth of population
recordings in granule cells
at the millisecond time
scales that are really needed
to interrogate this idea.
So, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: So I have a question.
So we actually had a journal
club on a few of your papers,
and one of the
questions that came up
was some of these
principles of computations
that you see for movement
in the cerebellum,
how do you think
they may generalize
to sort of cognitive
computations that
happen in the cerebellum
but may not necessarily
be related to movement?
ABIGAIL PERSON: Yeah,
it's such a good question.
It's really the
question of the hour,
and I think with [INAUDIBLE]
talk that-- the idea I think
would be that there's
sort of an expansion
of prefrontal cortices along
with the actual anterior--
actually, posterior and lateral
components of the cerebellum,
and those have evolutionarily
grown together.
And so I think it's
a very fair question.
And I can only wildly
speculate, and it's probably
completely wrong.
But may-- we know that
there's some heterogeneity
in the circuit elements that
are seen in the granule cell
layer in different lobules.
So, for example, I brought
up these unipolar brush cells
that Nate Sawtell has
sort of speculated about.
Those are found very densely
in vestibular components,
and I don't know
whether they're seen
in the more sort of
posterior lateral section--
segments.
But you might expect that time
constants of autocorrelation
are getting longer
and longer, and
that if the plasticity
mechanisms in the cerebellum
can keep up, I think there's
an eligibility trace question,
and maybe Jeff can sort
of enlighten us here.
But if the reverberation
throughout the brain
is robust enough to
consistently reactivate
the same kinds of cells
in the same cells, then
maybe there can be
essentially the same algorithm
about error and
association of predictors
to that that happens
in the motor regions
just at longer timescales.
So I think it's all
about time scales.
It's all about can you
get a longer basis set?
Are the eligibility
traces for the plasticity
that's required for change
sufficient for this?
So I don't know.
That's kind of hand-waving,
probably not very satisfying,
but yeah, it's a great--
it's a very interesting set
of questions.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks so much.
Are there any more
questions from the audience?
I can ask one more sort
of high level question.
So at ICON, a lot
of us are thinking
about how to adapt the existing
theories in various domains
to capture more and
more complex behavior.
So in-- and it's becoming
increasingly possible
to measure more accurately
complex behavior and movement
like higher degree of
freedom movements in animals
and movement across
longer timescales
in naturalistic environments.
So in what ways do you
think sort of these theories
and principles, say,
in the cerebellum,
would need to be adapted?
Or would it just
be more of the same
when you're trying to
explain complex behavior?
Or would they need to
fundamentally change
to explain sort of
more complex behavior?
ABIGAIL PERSON:
Yeah, I don't know.
I mean, I think
fundamentally, you
have to have sharp questions.
Otherwise, you're lost, right?
So I think that we can talk
about more complex behavior,
but what about more complex
behavior are we talking about?
Is it the complexity itself
is it something else?
Already, our behavior is
considered absurdly complex.
So different audiences
are like, oh, my God.
Unconstrained reaching,
are you kidding me?
So I mean, people that study
motor control want a two--
a planer, two-arm robot.
That's it.
So I think that we're making--
I think we have some
traction on this behavior,
and it's already complex.
And I think that
people can make headway
on much more complex tasks
if their questions are clear.
It's just a matter
of like what are
you-- what do you want to know?
SPEAKER 1: Thanks.